EVERY WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET --
BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY START AS A
SUB COMMITTEE IF MR WILK WOULD
LIKE TO GET GROWING ON A WELCOME
THE MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE.
THANK YOU FOR READING A LITTLE
BIT OFF OUR TIME SCHEDULE TODAY --
AND ARE TO BE EFFICIENT IN THE
GOVERNMENT'S WORK AND SO WE'LL
START WITH -- MR WILK WITH.
S..
SB.
ONE FIFTY THREE THANK YOU THAT
MEMBERS.
SB ONE COULD YOU PLEASE CONFIRM
THE STATE STATE PERMISSION ON
INTERNATIONAL HANDS AND
REQUIREMENTS FOR STATE LAND. ONE
OF THE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
FARMVILLE.
WELL CALIFORNIA STREAMLINING.
PRODUCTION WILL SECONDLY JUST
ASKED ME MORE FORTINO NINE ONE
OF THE LAST SEPTEMBER --
FOLLOWING -- DECEMBER THAT
HARBORS PASSED IN THE
PRESIDENT'S LINE JAR TO WHICH
WAS THE LATEST ITERATION OF THE
FARM.
UNDER SECTION ONE ZERO ONE ONE
THREE THE FARM BILL.
STATE DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
MOSTLY SOLVE THE GOVERNOR SHE
WALKED WORSEN OFFICER TO DEVISE
A PLAN AND MUST BE SUBMITTED.
THE US DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES A SECRETARY
CDS MAIN CONSULTATION WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO DEVELOP XNA STATE
PLAN THE SECRETARY THEN USDA
HARD WORK.
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THESE DAYS BY THE
LICENSE AND REGULATE CAMPAIGN
ONLY MEANS ONCE SECRETARY OF US
YEAH -- DASCHLE HAS ROOM THREE
THOUSAND TWO YEARS YEAH PROP.
AND FIBER IN FACT IS USUALLY
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DIFFERENT
PRODUCTS.
YEAH HAS ALLOWED THE FARMERS
MIGHT LOCAL GOVERNMENT THESE
POWERS ALREADY UNDER SECTION
SEVEN ARTICLE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTITUTION IN FACT THE VERY
FIRST SECTION OF THE BILL STATES.
I LIKE TO THINK THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU IN THE ROLE CAN
CITIZENS ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH US ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
MAYBE TODAY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS RIGHT THERE
ON THE CALIFORNIA.
OKAY AND IF YOU'LL HOLD ON A
MINUTE ALL HAVE THE SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL ALMOST ABBAS QUAN.
HERE.
HERE MATHIS [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY CUNNINGHAM FLORA.
LARA HERE GRAY [inaudible]
GRAY HAIR.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER HERE JONES
SAWYER HERE LEVINE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS HERE SALAS.
SALAS PRESENT IN COURT
[inaudible]
ARMISTEAD WISH.
OKAY FIRST PERSONS BEGIN SUPPORT
PLACE A MANAGER MEMBERS -- BRETT
BEAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA HIM
COUNSEL HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE FIVE THREE
IT'S AN EXCITING TIME FOR HELP
IN THE STATE -- THE THE ROOM THE
REGISTRATION REGULATIONS IN THE
TESTING RAGS ARE IN PLACE WE DO
HAVE SEEDS IN THE GROUND WHICH
IS.
IS A TRUE TESTAMENT TO
CALIFORNIA'S INITIATIVE TO STAY
AHEAD OF THIS THING I'M SB ONE
FIVE THREE IS A BILL TO CONFORM
TO THE FEDERAL FARM BILL.
AND WE BECAUSE WE WANT TO WE
WANT TO TO CONFORM AND NOT BE
DEFINED BY THAT BILL AND HAVE A
STATE PLAN THAT RESONATES WITH
WHAT WE PUT INTO PLACE AND
CONTINUE. TO BE SO SUCCESSFUL --
THIS IS A ONE BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY AND JUST CONTINUES TO
GROW -- WE ARE WE HAVE BEEN IN
CONSTANT COMMUNICATION WITH CDFA
ON THIS SO WE KNOW THE
COMPONENTS WILL FIT IT AND AND
AGREE WITH WHAT THEY HAVE IN
MIND.
AND WOULD LIKE TO URGE ALL IN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BLOCKS PERSONS BEACON
SUPPORT MANAGER MEMBERS PAUL
SMITH WITH THE REAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF REPRESENTING
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF THE
STATE'S RURAL COUNTIES I THINK
OF FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO
THINK ON SENATOR.
WILL FOR THOSE COMMENTS A WE
HAVE A SUPPORT OF AMENDED
POSITION -- WE ENVISION MOST OF
OUR MEMBERS -- WILL CONSIDER
HEMP AND YOU'LL SEE A LARGE
AMOUNT OF CULTIVATION IN OUR
MEMBER COUNTY SO WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT -- THIS OPPORTUNITY IN THE
COUNTIES THAT ARE EMBRACING THAT
THE ISSUE FOR OUR MEMBERS HAS
BEEN AS WE WORK THROUGH THIS
BILL IS HOW DO WE PRESERVE LOCAL
CONTROL AND MAKING SURE.
THERE ARE PROPER GUARD ROLES --
THAT CONFORM WITH THE FEDERAL
LAW THAT WAS ENACTED LAST
DECEMBER OUR VIEW LAST REQUEST
OF MANY THAT WE HAVE WORKED WITH --
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS IS
AN ISSUE DEALING WITH
ENFORCEMENT AND WHAT WE CALL
OCCUPY THE FIELD WE UNDERSTAND
THAT -- SENATOR WILL WILL LIKELY
ADDRESS THAT AMENDMENTS -- IN
THE NEXT ROUND OF AMENDMENTS --
THAT NEED TO BE MADE TO IT.
BUT WITH THAT WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE THINK
THIS IS A GOOD STEP IN THE
DIRECTION TO GET CALIFORNIA
CONFORMITY WITH FEDERAL LAW ON
THE CULTIVATION OF HIM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY ELSE
SPEAKING SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
VISION UP PEOPLE'S.
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KILLERS FROM CALIFORNIA FROM
HERE AND TRANSPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PEOPLE
SUPPORT PEOPLE SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MATTER CHAIRMAN CLIFF
BURKE HERE IN BEHALF OF SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY -- BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE ARE OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED TO THIS BILL AND
FOR US THE ISSUE WHICH IS
MENTIONED EARLIER IS LOCAL
CONTROL -- WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE ROLE COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
NEGOTIATING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS.
AND WILES AMENDMENTS WERE PUT IN
IN JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH THEY WERE
NOT THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
BELIEVE HAVE.
WERE GOING TO BE ADOPTED OR ON
THE TABLE OUR LETTER INDICATES
OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
BELIEVE ARE NECESSARY TO
PRESERVE LOCAL CONTROL.
AND WITHOUT STRONG PRESERVATION
OF LOCAL CONTROL WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT NEXT IN ESSENCE
THIS COULD BE INTERPRETED TO
OVERRIDE LOCAL ZONING AND
PLANNING -- PROVISIONS AND
THEREFORE -- THIS IS A FAIRLY
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE IN OUR AREA
AND WITHOUT THE STRONG
PROTECTIONS -- WE ARE OPPOSED AT
THIS TIME.
YOUR MUCH NEXT PERSON'S BEGIN
OPPOSITION.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS WAYNE RICHMOND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH FOUNDATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION.
OF FOR SOME OF YOU I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH PACKAGES
TODAY BUT I HAVE DELIVERED
PACKAGES THAT SPEAKS TO EXACTLY
ARE ISSUE.
WANT TO THANK SENATOR WILK FOR
SUPPORTING -- HAMP IN THE STATE
AND THANK ALL OF YOU WHO HAVE
SUPPORTED HIM WE WE GENERALLY
SUPPORT THIS -- BUILT BUT HAVE
AN ISSUE WITH THE REMOVING OF
THE EXEMPTION FOR ESTABLISHED
AGRICULTURAL RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS.
SO FAR THIS STATE WE ARE THE
ONLY ONES THAT HAVE ENABLE
FARMERS TO ACTUALLY GROW HIM.
UNDER RESEARCH CONDITIONS TO
DETERMINE THINGS LIKE SEED
VARIETIES THAT GROW WELL IN OUR
MULTIPLE.
MICRO CLIMATES THE PACKAGE THAT
I'VE GIVEN YOU TODAY INCLUDES A
SEVENTY PAGE SCIENTIFIC REPORT
FROM ONE OF OUR FARMS IN VENTURA
WHICH IS WELL KNOWN.
BY THE CDFA AND THE U. S. A..
AND AS SUCH I HAVE A PICTURE
HERE OF THE DEPUTY ADMINISTRATOR
FROM THE USDA VISITING OUR FARMS.
IT'S IN YOUR PACKAGE.
AND ALSO WE HAVE RECENTLY SIGNED
AN AMMO YOU WITH IMPERIAL COUNTY
TO HELP THEM BRING A AND PLANNED.
TO THEIR COUNTY SO WE ARE
PROVIDING A VERY IMPORTANT
FUNCTION.
THE FARMERS THEMSELVES ARE
ACTUALLY FINANCING THE FORMS OF
THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY AT THE AT
STAKE HERE.
AND MY CONCERN IS IF THAT THIS
GOES AWAY WE LOSE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR REAL RESEARCH UC DAVIS HAS
BASICALLY ABROGATED THEIR
POSITION ON THIS.
DATE WE WORK CO SPONSORS WITH
THEM OF THE US OF THE CAMP
SUMMIT LAST NOVEMBER.
THERE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR NEW HAMPSHIRE
CONSORTIUM IN MAY AND SUDDENLY
THAT -- WHICH WE WERE A WEEK
AWAY FROM CONSUMMATING SUDDENLY
BLEW UP TO OUR FARMERS ACTUALLY
HAVE NO OPPORTUNITY AS DID ALL
OF THE OTHER FARMERS IN ALL OF
THE OTHER STATES IN THE COUNTRY.
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY THROUGH THEIR
STATE DEPARTMENTS OF CULTURE AND
UNIVERSITIES TO CONDUCT RESEARCH
OUR STATE IS YEARS BEHIND IN
THAT.
IT WOULD BE A TRAVESTY FOR OUR
FARMERS TO HAVE THAT --
OPPORTUNITY CLOSED OUT TO THEM
WE HAVE BEEN THE STAKEHOLDERS --
FOR A YEAR AND A HALF NOW.
WE ACTUALLY ADDED SOMETHING TO
FOURTEEN OH NINE THAT HELPED IN
TERMS OF THE WILD WEST MISS IF
YOU WILL OF THE PREVIOUS BILL.
THAT REQUIRED NOTE.
NO COMMUNICATION WITH THE AG
OFFICES WE SUPPORTED THE GPS
COORDINATES BEING ADDED SO THAT
NOTICE WAS PROPERLY GIVEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY ELSE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TODAY
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THE WOULD YOU LIKE TO DRESS AS
WE ALL OF A DO THE FOR IT SO IF
ON THE FIRSTPART SO -- THE
RURAL COUNTIES WE ARE GOING TO
BE AS WE MOVE FORWARD TAKE
AMENDENTS THAT ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS THAT'S WHY THEY WANTED
THAT TO GO ON THE RECORD SO
THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
SENATE SANTA BARBARA COUNTY IS
IS LATE SO I DON'T KNOW IF THOSE
AMENDMENTS -- FIX THEIR CONCERNS
BUT OBVIOUSLY THEY REAPPEAR IN
THE SAME ISSUE SO HOPEFULLY AND
COURSE.
OF MISTER BERG KNOWS WHERE MY
OFFICE IS SO WE CAN WE CAN WORK
ON THAT TERMS OF THESE LAST
QUESTIONS IT.
THIS LAST NAME IS THE FIRST TIME
I'M HEARING ANY OF THIS BUT I
KNOW MISTER BURROUGHS IS IN A
POSITION -- TO TO FOLLOW UP WITH
AN ARTICULATE ON THAT YES
SECTIONS EIGHTY ONE HUNDRED OF
THE BILL DEALS WITH THE
ESTABLISHED RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS WHICH UNDER THE
LAND OF BILL -- PUT A BROAD
DEFINITION AND ALLOW -- RESEARCH
UNDER THE PILOT PROGRAMS WITH
BASED ON ANIMAL YEARS ANOTHER
TYPES OF MORE INFORMAL
AGREEMENTS AS WE PROGRESS WITH
THE FARM BILL SPECIFICALLY A
TWENTY FOURTEEN FARM BILL IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FARM BILL.
THOSE RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS WERE
MORE TIGHTLY DEFINED AND SO IN
MOST IT CLOSELY CLOSELY DEFINED
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN FARM BILL
SO WHAT WE'VE DONE.
IS ALLOW THOSE TO OPERATE UNTIL
THE STATE PLANS APPROVED BY THE
FEDERAL. TWENTY EIGHTEEN FARM
BILL WHICH WOULD THEN DEFINE IT
CONSISTENTLY WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS LAID OUT UNDER THE
UNDER THEIR FARM BILL SECTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I WONDER WHY.
THE LANGUAGE IS IN THERE RIGHT
NOW THAT IT IS THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN ENACTING THIS ACT.
TO NEITHER LIMIT NOR PREVENT A
CITY COUNTY OR CITY COUNTY FROM
EXERCISING AS POLICE POWER
AUTHORITY.
UNDER THE SECTION SIX OF THE
CONSTITUTION THE DOES THAT TO
SANTA BARBARA.
DOES THAT NOT FEEL LIKE IT
PROVIDES THE GUARDRAILS YOU'RE
LOOKING.
FOR THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN NO
WE DO NOT THINK THAT'S THAT IS
SUFFICIENT THAT INTENT LANGUAGES
VISION THE ORIGINAL LANGUAGE
PROPOSED.
WHICH IS CITED IN OUR LATER --
WE THINK IS NECESSARY YOUR SON
OR SOME VARIATION THEIR ARMY WAS
ON THE TABLE BY THE RURAL
COUNTIES FOR WHATEVER REASON I
BELIEVE IT WAS.
REJECTED -- WE WERE TOLD AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE LATENESS OF
OUR OPPOSITION BUT WE WERE TOLD
WANT LITERALLY ON MONDAY THAT
LANGUAGE WAS GOING IN.
ARM THROUGH OUR LOCAL OFFICES.
IN OUR LOCAL ACT COMMISSIONER
AND SO WE ACTUALLY VOTED ON
MONDAY TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
BASED UPON THE AMENDMENTS AND WE
ONLY LEARNED YESTERDAY AFTERNOON
THAT THE ORIGINAL LANGUAGE.
THAT WAS INTENDED FOR THE
PROTECT THE LOCALS WAS NOT GOING
IN AND THAT THAT INTENT LANGUAGE
WAS -- WHAT WAS AGREED TO WHICH
IT WAS NOT WHAT OUR
UNDERSTANDING WAS SO THEREFORE
WE HAVE TO REFER YOU KNOW TAKE
THE POSITION WE ARE?
TAKING WHICH IS THAT WE DON'T
THINK THAT INTENT LANGUAGES
VISION PROJECT LOCAL CONTROL AND
SETTING UP A STATE PROGRAM HERE --
HAS THE IMPLICATION OF ERODING
LOCAL CONTROL WITHOUT MAKING IT.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THAT'S THAT IS.
UP WITH THROUGH MORE DETAIL
LANGUAGE SO -- WE WOULD ASK THE
AUTHOR TO CONSIDER IN THE
SPONSORS CONSIDER.
INCLUDING OUR THE LANGUAGE OR
SOME VARIANT THE AS WAS
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED BY THE ROLE
COUNTIES.
WE ARE TAKING THAT.
WELL NO AND WHAT WHAT WHAT OKAY.
BUT WE ARE STILL GOOD WE ARE
STILL IN.
TALKS WHY DON'T WE JUST HEARD A
FROM THAT WE'VE AGREED TO I
APOLOGIZE TO THE AUTHOR BUT I
MEAN WE WERE WE WERE.
TOLD THE LOCAL ON MONDAY OKAY
OKAY YOU GAVE MY NETWORK AT OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ALRIGHT BUT
SO THAT'S A SO IT'S SORT OF
SITUATION WE WERE TOLD ONE THING
LEARN SOMETHING ELSE.
AND OUR FOLKS DO NOT THINK IT'S
SUFFICIENT OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALTHOUGH I I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT.
COUNTY COULD GO AHEAD PASSED AN
ORDINANCE TO ESTABLISH SAYS
THINGS [inaudible]
ARM.
I THINK THE CONCERN IS THAT THIS
THAT THE STATE LEGISLATION COULD
BE USED TO TRY TO PREEMPT THE
COUNTY THE COUNTY'S ABILITY TO
THROUGH ITS.
PLANNING AND ALL RIGHT THERE ARE
NO WORDS ON THIS AND OKAY THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ALL RIGHT OUT OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR THANK YOU SO JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION YOU WILL BE TAKING
SOME OF THESE AMENDMENTS MOVING
FORWARD IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE IS
JUST YEAH THE TIMING.
YEAH EXACT WAS IT WAS IT WAS A
TIMING ISSUE YEAH ABSOLUTELY
EVERITT WE ARE HAVING DRAFT AN
ANGRY.
TOO GOT IT THANK YOU.
AND I AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
ARE CENTER WILL FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AS A AS ONE OF THE
FATHERS OF CANNABIS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
AND YOU ALWAYS ARE YOU A THOMAS
JEFFERSON READ COMMERCE DROWNING
FOUNDING FARMERS WE LIVE ABOUT
ANYTHING ARMORS AND YOU DON'T
WANT IT TOLD ME THAT THE
FOUNDING FATHERS WERE.
FOUND IN HIM FARMERS OF A
HEARING IN THE STATES -- IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE WE MOVE
FORWARD AND TAKE THIS TO THE
NEXT LEVEL -- I KNOW A LOT OF
TIMES PEOPLE WONDER WHY THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SOUTH LA'S
ON THIS.
ON THIS COMMITTEE THIS IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
WE HAVE A THIS BILL IS A CANVAS
BILL AFTER THAT I THINK.
CANNABIS NEED TO BE DISCUSSED IN
THIS FORM RIGHT HERE ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO OF GROWING.
AND DISTRIBUTING SO OF I THANK
YOU FOR FROM MOVING TO SUPPORT
YOUR YOU'VE BEEN A LEADER IN
THIS -- AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW IT
I KNOW IT'S NOT ALWAYS EASY --
MOVING FOR WAS WITH A NEW CROP.
THAT'S NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE
AND IN THIS COUNTRY SO I COMMEND
YOU ON DOING THAT I COMMEND YOU
ALSO KNOW THAT YOU.
ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL.
ON RATS.
THAT IS PARAMOUNT WITH YOU IN
AND AND YOU WILL DO ANYTHING TO
MAKE TO YOUR DO EVERYTHING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY DON'T WE
DON'T YOU SIR THAT FROM THE
STATE SO.
I I'D LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
INVESTMENTS -- LATER ON AND AND
SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SOMEONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A AND I WOULD ALSO JUST ADD AYE
I HAVE BEEN A LONG ADVOCATE THAT
ALL THINGS I THINK -- GROWN A
SHOULD COME THINK AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE AND NOT AND NOT AS A
COMMITTEES -- BE THAT HOPS BE
THAT ONE GRAPES BE THAT HAVE
BEEN -- CANNABIS AND OR HELP --
YES THE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
ON THIS -- WE IN THE AGRICULTURE
COMMUNITY ALWAYS LOOKING FORWARD
TO NEW CROPS THAT ARE LESS WATER
INTENSIVE AND HAVE GREAT
RESEARCH TO BACK THEM UP AS A
REAL WAY INTO THE FUTURE -- SO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A CLOSING
STATEMENT YEAH.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
THE COMMENTS LA IT IS TRUE THIS
IS THIS CROP IS GOING TO
REVOLUTIONIZE -- CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTUREAND IT'S GOOD BRING
MORTGAGE PAYING -- JOBS TO
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF ALL THE
ALL THE ITEMS THAT -- HIPPIES
USED IN THE MANUFACTURING
PROCESS THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
HELLO TYSON SO ANYTHING YOU KNOW
DO WITH CARBON.
IN TERMS OF PLASTICS ARE GONNA
BE ABLE TO DO WITH TAP SO I I
THINK THIS MOVES FORWARD ON OUR
CLIMATE GOALS.
AND AND INCREASE AND CONTINUE TO
CREATE WEALTH IN CALIFORNIA SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
HOPEFULLY NOT JUST THE THE
GROWING UP BUT ALSO THE
MANUFACTURING OF PRODUCTS FROM A
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EGGMAN HI EGGMAN I MATHIS.
MATHIS SIGNED A GEAR CURRY
CUNNINGHAM FLORA.
FLORA I'D GRAY.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE HI ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVAS SIZE SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS SIGN.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WHILE YOU'RE HERE
MISTER WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO
IS BE TWO OH TWO AFTER THAT LAST
ONE I'M NOT SURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
YEAH WHAT'S.
THAT MAY COME UP OKAY GRATEFUL
PERFECT AND WE GOT DOCTOR ALWAYS
MOVE A LITTLE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AND APPRECIATE THAT FROM THE
VICE CHAIR TO START I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND ALL YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE FOR THE GREAT WORK.
I KNOW ON THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WHICH WE ACCEPT ALL
THOSE AMENDMENTS AND I BELIEVE
THAT THESE MEMBERS HELP MOVE THE
BILL FORWARD IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT I'VE
HAD AN ONGOING DISCUSSION WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE ANIMAL
BLOOD BANK.
WHAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO VOTE ON
THAT LANGUAGE TODAY I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORK WITH THEM TO
ENSURE ALL PERSONAL IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION OF THEIR ANIMAL
OWNERS IS PROTECTED FROM
DISCLOSURE?
I SB TWO OH TWO IS A VERY SIMPLE
YET NECESSARY FIX TO SERIOUS
PROBLEMS FACING THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL COMMUNITY.
THEN THERE IT VETERINARIANS ARE
FACING A SEVERE SHORTAGE OF
BLOOD RESOURCES IN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS MOST OF THE NATION.
THE EXISTING BLOOD BANKS SIMPLY
ARE PROVIDING ENOUGH FOR THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL THIS IS
ENDANGERING THE LIVES OF ANIMALS
WHO NEED BLOOD TRANSFUSIONS IN
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS.
IN MANY CASES THE ALTERNATIVE.
ALTERNATE TO A TRANSFUSION IS
DEATH -- ANYBODY DOUBTS THAT IF
YOU KNOW ROBIN BLACK SHE AN
EXPERIENCE LAST YEAR.
DODD WAS ILL WAS AT THE DEAD
HERE IN SACRAMENTO -- NEED A
BLOOD TRANSFUSION DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH PLASMA.
CLOSEST PLACE WAS IN DAVIS SO
SHE FRANTICALLY DROVE OUT AND
HER DOG PASSED IN HER FRONT SEAT
ON THE DRIVE TO DAVIS.
SB TWO OH TWO ALLOWS FOR THE
COMMERCIAL LICENSURE OF
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS
MEETING PEOPLE WOULD BE ABLE TO
VOLUNTEER THEIR PETS TO GIVE
BLOOD.
THIS JUST LIKE THE WAY PEOPLE
GIVE BLOOD WE GO WHEN WE DONATE
WE GO BACK HOME.
SURPRISINGLY THIS IS A LEGAL FOR
ANIMALS IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW
EVEN THOUGH ALL FORTY NINE OTHER
STATES ALLOW IT.
IN THIS STATE ANIMALS MUST BE
KEPT CRIMINALLY HOUSED ON
PREMISES TO DONATE BLOOD.
OTHERWISE THE FACILITY CANNOT BE
LICENSED SB TWO OH TWO ALLOWS
EXIST. TO EXIST AS THEY ARE BUT
ALSO MAKES FOR A NEW COMMUNITY
BLOOD BANKS WHICH WILL OPERATE
UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF THE
VETERINARIAN.
THIS ONE CLUE THIS ONE CREASES
SUPPLY A RUN A BLOOD PRODUCTS
ENSURE HEALTHY HAPPY PETS
EVERYWHERE.
THIS IS AN EASY AND COMMONSENSE
REFORM BUT IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
MAKE THE CHANGES NOW -- I HAVE A
COUPLE WITNESSES AND I WILL GO
UP GO AHEAD AND ALLOW THEM TO
SELF IDENTIFY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHICH
PERSONS GOOD MORNING I'M JUDY
MAN CREW SO FOUNDER AND
PRESIDENT OF SOCIAL COMPASSION
AND LEGISLATION.
I SERVED ON THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD FOR
OVER EIGHT YEARS AND I'M PROUD
TO SAY THAT WE ALONG WITH
SENATOR WILK STAFF AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF.
WITH INPUT FROM DR -- INS AND
PROFESSIONALS FROM THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD AND THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION HAVE WORKED HARD TO
MAKE THIS BILL GOOD FOR ALL
PARTIES FOR THE BLOOD BANKS FOR
CONSUMERS CALIFORNIA
VETERINARIANS AND FOR DONOR AND
RECIPIENT ANIMALS.
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS WILL ADD
TO THE MUCH NEEDED ANIMAL BLOOD
SUPPLY IN THE STATE AS SENATOR
WILK STATED.
AS WELL AS MATCHING OTHER STATES
BY NOT KEEPING ANIMALS IN CAGES
JUST TO BELIEVE THEM AND IT
OPENS UP A REVENUE SOURCE FOR
THE VETERINARIANS AROUND THE
STATE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS HUMANE TYPE OF PRACTICE
THANK YOU FOR COULD YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY AND WE HOPE
TO HAVE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PERSON
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS MORNING?
MY NAME IS DOCTOR SHAUNA ONCE
I'M HERE AS A CITIZEN TODAY BUT
I DO MY DAY JOB I AM A
DAVIS THE SCHOOL THAT OUR
MEDICINE.
AND I'M ALSO THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE UC DAVIS BETTER
BLOOD BANK -- SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX WHEN WE STARTED OUR
PROGRAM WE HAVE COLLECTED BLOOD
FROM OVER.
FIVE TO SIX THOUSAND ANIMALS
THAT ARE OWNED BY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY AND WE'VE TRANSFUSED
AT LEAST THAT MANY UNITS OF
BLOOD. TO ANIMALS COMING TO OUR
FACILITY IN DIRE NEED OF
TRANSFUSION SERVICES.
IN THAT TIME WE HAVE NEVER HAD
AN ADVERSE EVENT ASSOCIATED WITH
THE DONATION PROCESS. FOR WE
HAVE NEVER TRANSMITTED A
TRANSFUSION TREADMILL
TRANSMITTED DISEASE TO RECIPIENT
OF THOSE BLOOD PRODUCTS.
OUR INTENT WHEN WE STARTED THE
PROGRAM IS TO DEVELOP A MODEL
PROGRAM FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SUCH THAT LEGISLATION
SUCH AS AS SENATOR WORKERS PUT
FORTH.
THAT COULD BE THE MODEL FOR HELP
THE STATE COULD MOVE FORWARD.
AS A SENATOR WHAT SAID ALL FORTY
NINE OTHER STATES ARE ALLOWED TO
DO THIS IT IS RIGHT IT IS GOOD
IT IS GOOD MEDICINE IT'S GOOD
PRACTICE.
AND I CERTAINLY KNOW ONE THING
IS THAT.
I'VE WAITED FIFTEEN YEARS FOR
THIS LEGISLATION COME FOR NIGHT
I AM HONORED TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY I CANNOT THANK YOU ENOUGH
FOR THIS -- I'VE BEEN IN
TRANSFUSION MEDICINE BUT WELL
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
AND HAVE HAVE HOPE FOR THIS DAY
FOR A LONG TIME.
IF THIS LEGISLATION DOES NOT
MOVE FORWARD I CAN TELL YOU BY
THE END OF THE YEAR DOGS WILL
DIE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FOR LACK OF BLOOD PRODUCTS.
AND I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT IF
THIS LEGISLATION DOES MOVE
FORWARD THAT QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS WILL MOVE INTO THIS
THE ENTREPRENEURIAL SPACE THE
CREATE BLOOD PRODUCTS.
BLOOD BANKS AND AT THE END OF
THE DAY DOGS LIVES WILL BE SAVED.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WILL BE ABLE
TO ENGAGE IN THE THE PROCESS OF
HAVING THEIR ANIMALS DONATE
BLOOD [inaudible]
AND IT.
THE FINAL ANALYSIS VETERINARIANS
WILL HAVE THE TOOLS AT THEIR
DISPOSAL TO SAVE PEOPLE'S.
ANIMALS LIVES AND SO I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLUS PERSONS BEING BRIEFLY
PLEASE YES MY NAME IS NICHOLAS
SACKETT SOCIAL QUESTION
LEGISLATION I'M JUST HERE TO
HELP WITH ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE THE BILL LANGUAGE ITSELF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER PEOPLE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR NOT ROBINSON OF
THE HAVE THE IMEI DECIDED I DID
STATED SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AM J. MEMBERS MIKE DEALER
REPRESENT THE VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIR IN
YOUR ACCENT CONSULTANT VICTOR
FRANK RICH FOR WORKING WITH ALL
PARTIES ON THE MOMENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS FOR SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M ERIN
EVANS ON BEHALF OF ANIMAL LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
WHEN YOU PROP CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION WERE IN
SUPPORT BECAUSE OF THE PUBLIC
RECORDS PIECE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY PEOPLE
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
TODAY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JEFFREY LEE **** OF
GREENBERG TRAURIG ON BEHALF OF
ANIMAL BLOOD BANK.
THANK -- THE COMMITTEE THE CHAIR
AND THE STAFF AS WELL AS THE
AUTHOR -- IN ALL OF THE WORK
THAT'S GONE INTO THIS BILL TO
GET IT TO THIS POINT.
IF I COULD JUST SPEAKA MINUTE
TO SOME OF THE BACKGROUND AND
SOME OF THE POINTS THAT WERE
MADE.
A LIKE ROBIN BLACK THE FOUNDER
OF ANIMAL BLOOD BANK LOST HER
OWN ANIMAL -- WHEN THERE WAS NO
BLOOD AVAILABLE FOR TRANSFUSION --
HER NAME IS PAT KAUFMAN.
SHE DESERVES SOME RECOGNITION
FOR HAVING PIONEERED THIS AREA.
AT KAUFMAN -- WHEN ABOUT AFTER
THAT HAPPENED AND ESTABLISHED
THE FIRST ANIMAL BLOOD BANK
LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA?
THAT'S WHAT SHE DID TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM.
AND SINCE THEN I WOULD AGREE
WITH DR -- AND THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF ANIMAL LIVES HAVE
BEEN SAVED IN THIS STATE AND
ELSEWHERE BECAUSE OF THAT.
ALL FORTY NINE STATES DO PERMIT
COMMUNITY SOURCE DONORS.
ALL FORTY NINE STATES ALSO
PERMIT COLONY BASED.
BLOOD BANKS.
AND MANY EXIST OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA.
COLONY BASED BLOOD BANKS HAVE
HAPPY HEALTHY DONORS WHO PRODUCE
THE SAFEST HIGHEST QUALITY BLOOD.
THAT'S TRUE NOW AND IT'S GOOD TO
BE TRUE WITH COMMUNITY SORTS
DONORS AVAILABLE.
HOWEVER THERE IS A SHORTAGE WE
ALL AGREE ON THAT AND WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE AND WELCOME COMMUNITY
SOURCE DONORS TO THE POOL
BECAUSE WE NEED THAT BLOOD.
ON THE ISSUE OF THE P. I. WHAT
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE.
IS -- THE EXISTING PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL PROTECT THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION OF COMMUNITY SOURCED.
ANIMAL DONORS THE OWNERS OF
COMMUNITY SOURCE ANIMAL DONORS --
WERE ALSO TOLD THAT EXISTING LAW
AND THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT WOULD
PROTECT THE PERSONAL INFORMATION.
OF COLONY BASED ANIMAL DONORS
AND THE AMENDMENT WE'VE ASKED
FOR IS JUST TO MAKE CLEAR IN THE
BILL WHAT WE'VE BEEN TOLD IS
CLEAR IN THE LAW.
THAT'S A VERY SIMPLE AMENDMENT
YOU ELIMINATE THE TWO WORDS
COMMUNITY SOURCED IN THE BILL.
AND WE PROTECT ALL OF THE ANIMAL
OWNERS AT THAT IS NECESSARY WE
KNEW IT TWENTY YEARS AGO WHEN MY
CLIENT WAS THE SUBJECT OF AN
TOWARD ALLEGATIONS THAT WERE
PROVEN COMPLETELY FALSE AND WE
THOUGHT AGAIN RECENTLY.
WHEN THE OTHER BLOOD BANK -- HIM
A PAT WAS THE SUBJECT OF ALSO
AND TOWARD ALLEGATIONS AND WE'VE
SEEN IT RECENTLY IN CINEMA
COUNTY.
WITH SIX HUNDRED ANIMAL RIGHTS
ACTIVISTS STORMED A DUCK FARM A
HUNDRED OF THEM WERE ARRESTED SO
WE APPRECIATE -- EVERYONE'S HELP
IN MOVING FORWARD -- TO AVOID
THAT PROBLEM IN THE FUTURE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER PEOPLE
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
TODAY.
OKAY -- FOR WE GET QUESTIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND WE'RE
GOING TO ACTUALLY BE TAKING
THOSE AMENDMENTS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD OKAY SO YOU ARE GONNA BE
TAKING THE AMENDMENT TO SEDATE
DECK INDIVIDUALS OKAY SO IT IS
EVERYBODY NOT ONE FROM ONE SIDE
OR ANOTHER SO.
IT OFF OKAY OKAY ALL RIGHT SO WE
ALL HEARD THAT AS ITS MOVE
FORWARD OKAY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IN JUST REAL QUICKLY I THINK YOU
EXPLAINED IT TO ME IN MY OFFICE
OF WHEN WE CALL WE TALK ABOUT
ANIMALS OF VOLUNTEERING GIVING
THEIR BLOOD TO A WAVE DECAY --
THEY LIKE YOU HOW DO YOU KNOW
THEY'VE.
TERRACE [inaudible]
GIVING BLOOD.
YES THAT WOULD YOU ASKED ME OUT
FROM THE CITY I DON'T I'M NOT
FROM A RURAL AREAS I DON'T.
THINK THAT WAS BY FAR THE BEST
QUESTIONS I'VE EVER BEEN ASKED --
AND PROBABLY THIS THE THE SALLY
QUESTION.
SO THE MANNER IN WHICH THE
STANDARD OF CARE IN UNITED
STATES RIGHT NOW FOR A COMMUNITY
BASED BLOOD DONORS -- CANINE
DONORS IS THEY'RE VIEWED ALIVE
IN SIMILAR WAYS TO SEARCH AND
RESCUE DOGS OR CANINE COMPANION
DOGS THAT -- SOMEWHAT SELF
SELECT IN ORDER TO BE A DONOR
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT GIVE
INFORMED CONSENT.
OF THEIR BEHAVIOR AND THEIR
ASSESSMENT BY A TRAIN BETTER
PROFESSIONAL TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT.
THEY ARE AMENABLE TO THE PROCESS
IS IS SORT OF THE STANDARD OF
CARE -- AT OUR FACILITY --
PROXIMATE 10215% OF DOGS WASH
OUT OF OUR PROGRAMMING THEY COME
THEY DEMONSTRATE IN A MANNER --
AS WE'RE WORKING SLOWLY
THROUGHOUT SCREENING THEM TO BE
A DONOR IF THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
PART OF THAT PROCESS WE THANK
YOU FOR COMING IN.
I THANK THEM FOR THEIR TIME AND
WISH THAT WE CAN HELP THEM BUT
THEIR DOGS CLEARLY DEMONSTRATED
TO US -- BASED ON THE BEHAVIOR
THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO
PARTICIPATE.
AND MOVING FORWARD THAT WOULD BE --
WHAT I WOULD HOPE AS NEW
ENTREPRENEURS COME INTO THE
FIELD AS THEY WOULD ADOPT THOSE
BEST PRACTICES TO UNDERSTAND
THAT?
IN ORDER TO IF YOU DO THAT
SUCCESSFULLY THE COMMUNITIES
ENGAGED.
AND THE DOGS ARE PROTECTED.
THANK YOU BILL GREAT QUESTION.
GLAD YOU'RE NOT.
GOING BY A BARKER ME OUT NO.
NO NO NO.
NO NO YEAH I WAS ONE OF MY
ISSUES TO AS A AS A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER.
DOGS CANNOT GIVE INFORMED
CONSENT IS ALWAYS BEEN IN THIS
BECAUSE LAW THAT'S A BILL YOU
AND I DO TOGETHER.
OKAY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
GOOD.
SIR I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
LOOKING AT TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS MOVING FORWARD -- BUT
ALSO -- WITH THE CONCERN OF NOT
HAVING ENOUGH ANIMAL BLOOD
WITHIN THE STATE -- ALSO LOOKING
MAYBE OPENING IT UP FOR TAKING
OUT OF STATE BLOOD -- SO LONG AS
IT MEETS THE STANDARDS REQUIRED --
THAT WAY WE CAN ENSURE THINGS
LIKE HAPPEN -- TO ROBIN BLACK
AND OTHER FAMILIES -- DON'T
HAPPEN AGAIN.
SO THAT SOMETHING YOU MIGHT
WANNA LOOK AT GOING FORWARD
GREAT THANK YOU.
SHOULD APOLOGIZE TO ROBIN BLACK
I DIDN'T ASK ABOUT IT TO OUR
STORY BEFORE IS TOLD IT KIND
MADE FAMOUS THIS MORNING BUT THE
FIRST.
FOUR ONE SIX SEVEN OKAY.
OKAY THE AND THAT'S A GREAT IDEA
FOR FOR ANOTHER BILL.
I OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THEY AT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'D I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY SAID BETTER THAN DR --
AND SEE IF THIS DOES NOT BECOME
LAW DOGS DIE SO WITH THAT THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SIGNATURE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ON SB TO A TO THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS EGGMAN HI EGGMAN
AYE MATHIS [inaudible]
EXCUSE -- I'M SO WE NEVER GOT A
SECOND I MEAN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AGAIN EGGMAN MADAM CHAIR YOU'RE
ALREADY ASKING LIKE YOU'RE IN
THE SENATE.
ONLY TO THE ONE THAT MOTION IN
THE SAID.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I AGUIAR-CURRY CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I FLORA.
FLORA AYE GRAY IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER BY JONES SAWYER AYE
LEVINE.
LEVINE I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS SIZE SALAS.
SALAS SIGN.
THAT YOU'RE THAT YOU'RE IS OUT.
THE BILL IS OUT TAKE MANAGER
REGULATIONS -- LOOKING FOR AN
AUTHOR NOW.
GET NOTHING CONSENT OKAY
[inaudible]
YEAH.
HI GOOD FOR MISTERS MCGUIRE DODD
[inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I MIGHT [inaudible]
WHAT?
IF YOU'RE COMING.
I WOULD SUGGEST MEMBERS SHOW UP
IF YOU WANT TO KEEP A QUORUM
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
MOBILE [inaudible]
I YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
NO
.
THAT'S A REALLY.
IS THAT.
RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible] FIVE YEAH.
THEY WERE IRATE AFTER.
THAT -- LAST YEAR.
WHAT OPTION THEN [inaudible]
YEAH -- OF COURSE
[inaudible]
THAT IS
WE WILL [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH
. TO THE WORLD
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WE HAVE AN ULCER.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR -- HERE TO
PRESENT.
SB.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I THANK YOU VERY THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT SB FIVE TWENTY SEVEN A
MEASURE THAT WOULD ALLOW
CANNABIS IN INDUSTRIAL HEMP
CULTIVATORS. TO RECEIVE THE SAME
PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENT AND
RELIEF.
AS AT OTHER AGRICULTURAL SECTORS
IN THE STATE BY INCORPORATING
THEM INTO THE WOOD WILLIAMSON
ACT.
WHEN I THINK THE COMMITTEE IN
THE STAKEHOLDERS FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THESE AMENDMENTS WILL
BE ACCEPTING THEM TODAY?
THE CALIFORNIA LAND CONSERVATION
ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE ALSO
KNOWN AS THE WILLIAMS AN ACT
ESTABLISH A MEANS OF PROTECTING
AGRICULTURAL.
AND OPEN SPACE LAND BY REDUCING
THE BURDENS IMPOSED BY RISING
PROPERTY TAX RATES.
THE ACT ALLOWS PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS TO INTER INTER COULD
INTO CONTRACTUAL AGREEMENTS WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO
VOLUNTARILY RESTRICT THEIR LAND
TO AGRICULTURAL AND COMPATIBLE
OPEN SPACE USES.
THIS RESULTS IN SUBSTANTIALLY
REDUCE PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENTS
WHICH ARE BASED UPON INCOME
GENERATED RATHER THAN POTENTIAL
MARKET VALUE OF THE PROPERTY.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT THE
WILLIAMSON ACT SAGE AGRICULTURAL
LANDOWNERS ANYWHERE FROM 2275%
OF PROPERTY TAX LIABILITY.
EACH YEAR HOWEVER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AT THEIR DISCRETION
ARE ABLE TO DETERMINE WHICH AG
PRODUCTS ARE DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS TAX SAVINGS. FOR EXAMPLE IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY CANNABIS
CULTIVATION IS EXPELLED
EXPLICITLY CONSIDERED AS
INCOMPATIBLE AGRICULTURAL USE OF
LAND WHERE ITS CULTIVATION OF
CROPS SUCH AS FRUIT.
AND NUTS -- PLANT PRODUCTS AN
ANIMAL PRODUCTS ARE ALL
CONSIDERED ACCEPTABLE.
SB FIVE TWENTY SEVEN WOULD LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD AND PROVIDE
THAT THE CULTIVATION OF CANNABIS
PURSUANT TO CERTAIN TYPES OF
CULTIVATOR LICENSES.
ISSUED THROUGH THE MEDICAL AN
ADULT USE CANNABIS REGULATION
AND SAFETY ACT.
IS IS A COMPATIBLE LAND USE AND
UNDER THE WILLIAMSON ACT
CONTRACT IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
INCLUDE CANNABIS CULTIVATORS SO
THAT THEY CAN RECEIVE THE SAME
TAX ASSESSMENTS AS OTHER
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS.
SB FIVE TWENTY SEVEN IS A SMALL
BUT IMPORTANT STEP. TO ACHIEVE
THIS A EQUITY -- WITH ME TODAY
IS CASE YEAR CONNOR FROM THE
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE AND
PAUL SMITH FROM RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SUSAN
SPEAKING AT PORT PLEASE THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE CASEY
O'CONNOR LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR STATE TREASURER FIONA MOCKS.
PROUD TO BE HERE AS A SPONSOR OF
SB -- FIVE TWENTY SEVEN AS
PREVIOUSLY STATED SB FIVE POINT
SEVEN SIMPLY CLARIFIES EXISTING
LAW THAT CANNABIS AND HEMP
CULTIVATORS ARE ELIGIBLE TO BE
INCLUDED IN PROPERTY TAX
ASSESSMENT RELIEFAS OTHER AG.
IN THE STATE BY INCORPORATED IN
THE BLAMES AN ACT WITH CANNABIS
AS COMPATIBLE USE ONLY AND HELP
AS COMPATIBLE OR AG USE AS PER
THE DISTRICT ALLOWS.
IN THE TREASURES TIME SERVING ON
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION WE HAD
SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE
NEWLY LEGALIZED REGULATED
PRODUCTS.
OF HAVE BEEN CANNABIS AND
WHETHER THEY HAVE A PLACE IN THE
WILLIAMON ACT AND OUR
CONVERSATION TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSERVATION WHICH WOULD MAKE
CLEAR THEY DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL.
WHEN WE WERE SPEAKING WITH THEM --
RATHER HAVE BEEN CANNABIS
INDUSTRIES WE LEARNED THAT THERE
IS A LOT OF CONFUSION AS TO HOW
THESE PRODUCTS INTERSECT WITH
THE WILLIAMS ACT.
SO WITH THE HIGH TAXES ALREADY
AROUND CANNABIS AND SEEING LAST
ENTRY INTO THE REGULATED MARKET
AS CALIFORNIA PREDICTED THE
TREASURE AND STAKEHOLDERS
DISCUSSED UNIQUE WAYS TO TRY TO
INCENTIVIZE MORE CANNABIS
CULTIVATORS.
ENTERING INTO THE LEGAL MARKET
WE BELIEVE CLARIFYING EXISTING
LAW THAT SAYS FARMERS CAN
INCORPORATE CANNABIS AS A
COMPATIBLE USE FOR THE
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY WILL GIVE
THEM GREATER AND SPENT A
INCENTIVE TO EXPAND LEGAL
OPERATIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
SB FIVE POINT SEVEN SIMPLY
CLARIFIES THAT CANNABIS IS
COMPATIBLE USE ONLY HEMP CANDY
CONCERT AGRICULTURAL COMPATIBLE
USE.
AND THIS MEANS THAT FARMERS WHO
GROW ANOTHER APPROVED CROP ON
WILLIAMS ACTUALLY AND CAN ALSO
CHOOSE TO GROW LEGAL CANNABIS
AND THE COUNTY ASSESSOR HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO INCLUDE THEIR
APPRAISAL OF THE LAND.
ONLY IN COUNTIES THAT ARE
ACCEPTING Là EVEN ACT
APPLICATIONS THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE CURRENT LAW IT SIMPLY
CLARIFIES UP FOR THE COUNTIES
AND THE ASSESSORS TO UNDERSTAND
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BENJAMIN MEMBERS PAUL SMITH WITH
THE RURAL COUNTIES AGAIN WE
REPRESENT THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THOSE RURAL
COUNTIES IT IS OUR MEMBERS WHO
MAKE OF THESE CLAIMS AND ACT
CONTRACTS AND I WERE GOING VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION THAT THIS BILL
PROVIDES.
AND WE'RE ALSO VERY PLEASED WITH
THE CONSTRUCT OF THE BILL IS
MADE MAKING SURE THAT IT IS IN
FACT BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WHO
ULTIMATELY MAKE THAT DECISION --
THROUGH AN AFFIRMATIVE VOTE --
BY THE BY ABOARD SO WE REALLY --
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT'S GONE
INTO THIS BILL AND URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ADOPT SPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PERSON
SPEAKING SUPPORT PLEASE MANAGER
MEMBERS ANY FRANK ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MANAGER MEMBERS BRADBURY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HIM COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TELEVISION
WITH A CALIFORNIA FIRM HERE WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
BUT WE VERY MUCH LIKE TO THINK
MISS CABALLERO AND MISTER MISS
MáS STAFF AND WORKING THROUGH
OUR ISSUES.
AND FINDING A BONA FIDE PATHWAY
FORWARD FOR LEGITIMATE AKROPOLIS
CAN -- LIKE INDUSTRY THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
TODAY.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MR MATHIS TWENTY THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS ONE I KNOW THIS IS A TOUGH
SUBJECT -- IN THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE AND EVERYBODY
WORKING HARD ON THIS -- ONE I
STILL HAVE SOME LOCAL CONCERNS
BACK HOME SO I'LL BE LAYING OFF
OUT OF RESPECT TODAY BUT I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING HOW THIS MOVES
FORWARD.
THANK THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WHAT ELSE.
OKAY YEAH I I APPRECIATE THIS
COMING FORWARD IT'S PERMISSIVE
AND CLARIFYING ANOTHER OR THE I
THINK THAT'S THE KIND OF THINGS
THAT WERE WERE LOOKING -- FOR
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE OKAY THE DO WE
HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
THE SECOND.
I'LL SECOND IT.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON SB FIVE TO SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS EGGMAN HI EGGMAN AYE
MATHIS [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO.
FLORA.
FLOOR NOT VOTING.
GRAY.
IRWIN AYE IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
LEVINE.
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
SALAS. FOR CALLING THE BILL'S
UNCLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR.
OKAY -- AND NEXT UP I SEE MISTER
MCGUIRE AWAY.
YEP THIS REQUIRES UP NEXT.
WELL ORDER AND ARE YOU STILL
CHEERING [inaudible]
YES OKAY.
YOU ARE HERE PRESENTING MISTER
MCGUIRE ON SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE
HAVING TO DO WITH CANNABIS
MARKETING YES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
NEIGHBORS SAID.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M GONNA BE
VERY QUICK IN WITNESSES WILL
ALSO BE VERY QUICK IT CLARIFIES --
THE PROCESS IN REGARDS TO ALL
ISSUES ORGANIC CERTIFICATION --
AS WELL AS ALL ISSUES RELATED TO
AN APPELLATION -- ON THE ORGANIC
SITE IS FULL DISCLOSURE TO
MEMBERS ORGANIC LANGUAGE WAS
ACTUALLY TAKEN IN THE BUDGET AND
WILL NEED TO BE AMENDED OUT.
IN APPROPRIATIONS PENDING -- THE
CHAIR WOMAN IN THE COMMITTEE'S
APPROVAL -- AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN HIGH BUT
THANK YOU.
PERSONS BECAUSE APPARENTLY MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY -- LINDSEY ROBINSON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ARE WE REPRESENT
OVER FIVE HUNDRED LICENSED
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE -- AND
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL AND THINK
THE OFFER OFFER BRING IT FORWARD
THANK YOU.
THINK ISIS BEGINS PARK THANK YOU
SENATOR GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TERRA
CARVER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE
REPRESENTING TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
PLUS LEGAL CANNABIS IS AN
HUMBOLDT.
CANNABIS BUSINESSES -- WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
PEOPLE SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING IN PAUL'S WITH WITH
THE RURAL COUNTIES ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
CAROLINE NUMBER THE HUMBLED AND
THEN AS YOU KNOW COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS UP IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ASHLEY WALKER WITH MODERATE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT.
TED MAUL HAUSER WITH CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE -- EXPEDIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALONG WITH ALL THESE WITH UNITED
CANNABIS BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH EVERY SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL TODAY.
PLEASE COME FOR OKAY OF
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
OF I WOULD JUST SAY THANK YOU
OFFER ME I THINK IT'S BEEN A
GOOD DAY IN AGRICULTURE
COMMITTED TO CREATING MORE JOBS
AND MARKETS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO.
GOOD FOR US WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH THE COMMITTEES WELL
FOR ALL YOUR WORK I THINK THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
EGGMAN AYE EGGMAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I FLORA.
FLORA I'D GRAY IRWIN -- WHEN I
JONES SAWYER?
LEVINE ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS
SIZE SALAS.
SALAS SIGN WITHOUT THE BILL'S
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
AND CHECK THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- CENTER DODD YOU'RE
UP WITH ENVIRONMENTAL FORMING
INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
BUILDING MOVED AND SECONDED --
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB TWO
FIFTY THREE WOULD REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
NAY CULTURE. TO ESTABLISH THE
MINISTER AND INSTEAD OF BATES
CONSERVATION PROGRAM.
LET ME BEGIN BY FIRST SAME WILL
ACCEPT -- I I WILL BE ACCEPTING
ALL THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS IN
THE IN THE BILL ANALYSIS -- SB
TWO FIFTY THREE WOULD REQUIRE
THE INCENTIVE BASED CONSERVATION
PROGRAM TO OPTIMIZE WILDLIFE
HABITAT WHILE SUPPORTING.
ECONOMIC VIABILITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE THROUGH INCENTIVES
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
FARMERS.
AND RANCHERS -- THE MAJOR
DECISIONS A CONSERVATION
PRACTICE OF FARMERS AND RANCHERS.
CAN BE DRAMATICALLY ENHANCED --
DRAMATICALLY ENHANCE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AND
PROVIDE RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND SOCIAL
BENEFITS.
IN RECENT YEARS THE DELIVERY OF
ON FARM PRACTICES HAS DECLINED
THE CLIENT IS DRIVEN BY THE
RISING COST OF AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTION INCLUDING WATER AND
ENERGY.
MORE RESOURCES AND TOOLS ARE
NEEDED FOR CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS
AND RANCHERS TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE AND PROVIDE MULTIPLE
CONSERVATION BET BENEFITS.
THROUGH ON FARM PRACTICES.
THE PURPOSE OF THE INCENTIVE
BASED CONSERVATION PROGRAM IS TO
PROVIDEASSISTANCE TO
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCERS WHO WANT
TO VOLUNTARILY MAKE WILDLIFE
FRIENDLY IMPROVEMENTS ON THEIR
LET.
UPON A FUTURE APPROPRIATION THE
PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE FINANCIAL
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO AG
WORKER AG PRODUCERS SKEWS ME WHO
CREATE FISH AND WILDLIFE HABITAT
IT PROVIDE ADDED ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS SUCH AS IMPROVED WATER
QUALITY ROSA CONTROL.
A CONCISE CONSERVED --
GROUNDWATER YES BE TWO FIFTY
THREE CLEARLY.
INSTRUCTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE.
THAT I WHAT I'M GOING TO REPEAT
THIS THE STATE'S INSURED THE
INCENTIVE BASED CONSERVATION
PROGRAM.
COMPLIMENTS AND NOT SUB PLANTS
IN THE OTHER EXISTING PROGRAMS
SB TWO FIFTY THREE IS SUPPORTED
BY THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WHICH
IS HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FIRST PERSON
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT PLEASE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS LIZ FORCE BURKE AND I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR POLICY FOR
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
WE ARE HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ARE SB.
TWO FIFTY THREE OF CALIFORNIA'S
APPROXIMATELY HUNDRED MILLION
ACRES FORTY THREE MILLION ACRES
ARGUES FOR AGRICULTURE AND HE'S
WORKING FARMS AND RANCHES
PRODUCE MUCH OF THE COUNTRY'S
FOOD AND FIBER.
HE'S WORKING LAND ALSO PROVIDE
MUCH OF OUR STATES OPEN SPACE
AND THE HABITATS THAT WILDLIFE
NEED.
SB TWO FIFTY THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH A NEW PROGRAM PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCERS WHO WANT TO
VOLUNTARILY MAKE CONSERVATION
IMPROVEMENTS ON THE LAND.
WITH THE HELP FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING INCENTIVE
PROGRAM CREATED SB TWO FIFTY
THREE PRODUCES WOULD BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT ON FARM PRACTICES THAT
DELIVER ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
SUCH AS IMPROVED WATER AND AIR
QUALITY.
CONSERVE WATER GROUNDWATER AND
SURFACE WATER AND CREATE
WILDLIFE HABITAT.
SOMEBODY'S HABITAT PROJECTS
COULD INCLUDE WILDLIFE FRIENDLY
FENCING FOR SAFE WILDLIFE
MOVEMENT OR FLOODING RICEVILLE
FOR MIGRATORY BIRD HABITAT.
IN THE RECENT YEARS WE'VE SEEN
THE DELIVERY OF ON FARM
CONSERVATION PRACTICES DECLINE
FOR EXAMPLE SOME DAYS DURING THE
DROUGHT WE SAW A 100%.
OF BE CONSERVATION PRACTICES AND
HABITAT DELIVERED BY OUR FOR OUR
FARMERS AND RANCHERS.
MORE RESOURCES AND TOOLS ARE
NEEDED FOR CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS
AND RANCHERS TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE AND PROVIDE MULTIPLE
CONSERVATION BENEFITS TO ON FARM
PRACTICES.
SB TWO FIFTY THREE WITH SUPPORT
SCIENCE DRIVEN INVESTMENTS THAT
DELIVER BENEFITS TO THE PUBLIC
ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT CAN BE
REASONABLY EXPECTED THAT LENDERS
CAN PROVIDE ON THEIR OWN.
AND WE URGE YOUR IPHONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PERSONS BECAUSE FOR PLEASE.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MARK
FRIENDSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
TWO FIFTY THREE IN A RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS WERE
CREATED BACK IN THE DUST BOWL
ERA -- TO WORK WITH THE UNITED
STATES BERMAN AGRICULTURAL
NATIONAL RESOURCE CONSERVATION
SERVICE AND WE'VE REALLY
BENEFITED FROM THIS RELATIONSHIP
WE HAVE WITH OUR CS.
AND WORK WITH THEM IN SOME OTHER
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM WHICH
FACILITATES AMMAN FARM PRACTICES
THAT PROVIDE BENEFITS THAT
SENATOR DODD AND MISS FORSBERG
SPOKE -- TO WHAT WE SEE THIS
BILL DOING IS CREATING A STAY
ANALOG TO AN RC ASPER A PROCESS.
AND WILL GIVE US MORE TOOLS SO
THAT WE CAN WORK WITH FARMERS
AND RANCHERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IN A WAY THAT MATCHES OUR UNIQUE
AGRA KANA ME.
THERE ARE SOME PRACTICES THAT I
THINK WE WOULD.
LIKE TO SEE THE STATE FACILITATE
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SIMPLY CANNOT.
ARM.
AND WE'RE RELEASED APPRECIATIVE
OF CENTER DOT FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE PEOPLE
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLACE NAME
AFFILIATION AS MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MERION WARMER
DOWN ON BEHALF OF RURAL COUNTIES
HOME TO MANY OF THESE WILDLIFE
AREAS.
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE OF
THE MEASURE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THE PEOPLE SPEAK
AND SUPPORT PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS REBEKAH
BASQUE AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RICE COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ADAM ROBIN WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PEOPLE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL TODAY.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DAY RUN SEND POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR COMMUNITY LINES
WITH FAMILY FARMERS.
AND I WANT TO BE HERE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL -- BUT I HAVE TO
PROBLEMS AND CENTER DOT IS BY
SENATOR SO I I'M I'M NOT AT ALL
HAPPY TO BE IN THIS POSITION --
SO DESPITE THE INCLUSION OF THIS
AMENDMENT THAT SENATOR DODD --
TALKED ABOUT -- WHICH SAYS THAT
THE DEPARTMENT SHALL ENSURE THE
PROGRAM COMPLIMENTS AND DOES NOT
SUPPLANT EXISTING PROGRAM.
THE BILL STILL REQUIRE CDFA TO
ADOPT ALL AND ARTS YES PRACTICES
THAT ARE APPLICABLES TO
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT WOULD INCLUDE ALL THE
PRACTICES THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM THIS WEEK
PROGRAM THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM.
THEY'RE ALL APPLICABLES TO
CALIFORNIA -- WHY NOT LET CDF A
CHOOSE WHICH PRACTICES ARE MOST
APPROPRIATE TO THIS PROPOSED
PROGRAM -- HALF OF THE N. RCS A
QUICK MONEY FOR INSTANCE GOES TO
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE TYPES OF
THINGS THINGS THAT HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH WILDLIFE HABITAT.
AND MY SECOND POINT IS THAT THE
BILL SAYS THE DEPARTMENT MAY
GIVE PRIORITY TO PROJECT THAT
OCCUR IN AND BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
BUT THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A
BILL LAST YEAR AB.
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- WHEN THAT
SPELLS OUT HOW TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SHOULD BE PROVIDED
FOR HEALTHY SOILS SWEET?
AND ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
INCLUDING TARGETING SMALLER
FARMS LESS THAN FIVE HUNDRED
ACRES AND SETTING ASIDE 25% OF
FUNDS FOR SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGE.
FARMERS WHICH THAT FORMER EQUITY
ACTIVE TWENTY SEVENTEEN FROM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUILAR CURRY
DEFINED AS FARMERS OF COLOR.
IF SB TWO FIFTY THREE IS NOT
AMENDED TO TAKE ACCOUNT OF THIS
THEN IT REQUIRES CDFA TO
CONTRACT WITH THE ARE JUST SEE
DIS BUT DOESN'T OBLIGATE THEM TO
DO ANYTHING FOR FARMERS OF COLOR.
AND IT WILL INCLUDE ALL OF THE
SAME PRACTICES AS THE ALREADY
EXISTING PROGRAMS SO THERE'S TWO
THINGS HERE THAT NEED TO BE
AMENDED IN SOME WAY.
AND WE'VE BEEN TRYING -- TO TALK
TO THE SPONSORS AND TO CENTER
DOT ABOUT THIS BUT WE'RE STILL
STUCK HERE.
THANK YOU NEXT PERSONS BEGIN
OPPOSITION PLACE GENERAL POLICY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE IN AGRICULTURE NETWORK --
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WE ARE ALSO IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED -- POSITION -- IF SB TWO
FIVE THREE HAD BEEN BEFORE US
BACK IN TWENTY TWELVE I THINK WE
WOULD HAVE EMBRACE IT MORE HOLY
BECAUSE THE STATE WAS NOT IN A
POSITION OF PROVIDING INCENTIVES
OR TECHNICAL SYSTEMS FOR FARMERS.
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING
PRACTICES -- BUT GIVEN THE FOCUS
ON CLIMATE CHANGE AND GIVEN THE
NEEDS TO WORK WITH -- PRODUCERS
TO ADDRESS -- GREATER WEATHER
EXTREMES IMPROVE CARBON SINKS
SAVE WATER AND ENERGY WE NOW
HAVE A PRETTY ROBUST SUITE OF
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE
CURRENTLY SB -- TWO FIVE THREE
WE BELIEVE FAILS TO BE
COMPLEMENTARY TO AND NOT TO PLAY
COULD HAVE OF THOSE EXISTING
INCENTIVE PROGRAM SO WE HAVE
BEEN.
IN CONVERSATION SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE BILL'S
INTRODUCTION WITH THE SPONSORS
AND WITH THE AUTHOR TO TRY AND
FIND AMENDMENTS -- WE WOULD
AGREE WITH THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS THAT THERE'S A
ESPECIALLY IN NEED TO HAVE A
STREAMLINED APPLICATION PROCESS
SO THEY'RE NOT WORK WE'RE NOT
CREATING A COMPLEX SYSTEM FOR
FARMERS.
ON THE GROUND ALSO IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHAT THE INTENT OF THE
PROGRAM IN TWO FIVE THREE IS IS
IT A WILDLIFE HABITAT BILL IS IT
A CLIMATE CHANGE BILL WHY ARE WE
CREATING IF IT IS CLIMATE CHANGE
WE HAVE EXISTING CLAIM IT'S MORE
LIKE A CULTURE PROGRAMS -- HOW
CAN WE DO A BETTER JOB OF BEING
COMPLIMENTARY TO THOSE CURRENT
EFFORTS AND NOT DUPLICATIVE AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN SO WE ARE ALSO
INTERESTED IN SEEING GREATER
INCENTIVES FOR FARMERS AND
RANCHERS AS THE BILL LAYS OUT --
BUT CAN'T SUPPORT THE EFFORT
CURRENTLY UNTIL WE GET SOME
AMENDMENT LANGUAGE THAT REALLY
SEEKS TO IMPROVE -- PROGRAM
COORDINATION ACROSS THE BOARD
THANK YOU OTHER PEOPLE SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL TODAY.
OKAY BEFORE WE GET QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE -- CENTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND TO ANY
OF THE SO AND IT'S ALWAYS GOOD
WHEN YOU'RE OPPOSITION IS OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
USE THAT TELLS YOU THAT YOU'RE
STILL IN CONVERSATION.
WHAT IT RESPONDED THAT SECOND?
PART THAT.
YES SO WE HAVE BEEN
CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH ASSEMBLY
AFTER RESOURCES AND ASSEMBLY
ATTIC ON FIXING THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
LANGUAGE TO TRY TO ADDRESS WHAT
WE'VE SEEN FROM BOTH AS A MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY.
THAT'S A NUMBER IRWIN -- AND SO
WE ARE COPING ADDRESS THAT AND
APPROPRIATIONS.
OKAY TO THE TO THE INTENT IS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS.
OKAY OKAY -- OKAY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISS A WORKER
SO I APPRECIATE YOU'RE GONNA
LOOK AT THE DISPATCH FARMERS
DEFINITION MAKING SURE WE WORK
ON THAT WE WERE TAUGHT ON THE
BILL.
MY CONCERN AND I'VE TRIED.
TO FIND IT IN HERE BUT HOW IN
SENATORS -- HOW THE INCENTIVES
CAME ABOUT WHAT KIND OF
CALCULATIONS I WANT TO WARN YOU?
IF CALLUM BEIRA SCREEN SHOWS ITS
UGLY HEAD IN THIS I WILL NOT
VOTE FOR ON THE FLOOR.
BECAUSE I'VE HAD THE SLIP BY A
COUPLE OF TIMES NOW AND I'M
ALWAYS THE ONLY NO VOTE ON THE
FLOOR BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY I'M
I'M REALLY ADAMANT.
THAT WE ARE ALL INCLUDED IN THE
KIND OF CALCULATIONS THAT ARE
OUT THERE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RIGHT I THINK WE WANT TO ADDRESS
THAT BY CITING FOOD AND COAT
FIVE TWELVE WHICH IS.
A THAT THE BILL THAT YOU RAN
LAST YEAR.
JUST MAKING SURE.
HI FOR THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW
CALAVERAS GREEN EXCLUDES SOME
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE CLEAN AIR
BUT HAVE HIGH LEVELS OF POVERTY
SO -- WE APPRECIATE THE THE THE
MEMBER FROM LAKE COUNTY
[inaudible]
HAVING [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
OKAY OF WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SENATOR SPECTER ASKED RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR SIGNATURE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
I SB TWO FIFTY THREE THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
EGGMAN BY EGGMAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I AGUIAR-CURRY.
A GEAR CURRY I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I FLORA.
FLORA I GRAY.
GRAY I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER.
LEVINE.
LEVINE HI ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS EYES SALAS.
SALAS SIGN.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- WELL WE'RE HAVING AT THE
CENTER MONNING COME UP TO ME
SIGNATURE GOING PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON ON SOME OF THE BILLS
THAT WE'VE MISSED.
WE'LL START WITH
BILL THAT'S ON CALL.
ON SB FIVE TWENTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS.
A GEAR CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I GRAY.
GREAT I JONES SAWYER LEVINE.
LEVINE I SALAS EVER SHARE THE
OTHERS.
THE BILL IS OUT OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL GO AHEAD WITH YOU
SENATOR PLEASE -- SB SIX TWENTY
SEVEN SEAS.
SIX FIFTY SEVEN ALL RIGHT.
AS A DISTRACTION THE THINGS THAT
YOU THERE IS A TYPO ON MIND BY
GLASSES ARE FINE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SO
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY SEVEN
AUTHORIZES THE COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER TO
REPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE ON THE CONDITION.
ACREAGE PRODUCTION IN VALUE OF
CANNABIS THIS INFORMATION WOULD
BE IN ADDITION TO THEIR ANNUAL
CROP REPORT SUBMITTED.
THIS IS VOLUNTARY IT ALLOWS BUT
IT DOES NOT REQUIRE SOME
COUNTIES ARE FINDING THAT
BECAUSE CANNABIS IS CURRENTLY
NOT INCLUDED IN THE ANNUAL CROP
REPORT.
IT IS NOT AN ACCURATE
REPRESENTATION OF A COUNTIES
AGRICULTURAL CULTIVATION
NORMALIZING CANNABIS IS AN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT WILL
ENCOURAGE UNLICENSED GROWERS TO
COME FORWARD BECOME LEGITIMATE.
IT'D IN TAX PAYING BUSINESSES I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND ANY
APPROPRIATE TIME AND WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT THE BILL WITH THIS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MOVED AND SECONDED
PERSON RISEN PLACEMENT SUPPORT
PLEASE SHARON MEMBERS ACTUALLY
WALKER WITH NOT CEMENT ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF MONTEREY WHERE
THE PROUD SPONSOR OF SB SIX FIVE
SEVEN WHICH GIVES THE COUNTIES
THE OPTION TO REPORT CANNABIS
PRODUCTION DATA IN A SEPARATE.
BUT SIMILAR MANNER TO THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS CROP
REPORTS MONTEREY COUNTY WAS HOME
TO THE CUT FLOWERS INDUSTRY IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
GLOBAL COMPETITION PARTICULARLY
FROM LATIN AMERICA DECIMATED
THAT MARKET AND NOT THAT
DOWNTURN LEFT A BUNCH OF
COLLAPSING GREENHOUSES WHICH
PLAYED A HUGE ROLE IN PUSHING
THE LOCAL UNEMPLOYMENT RATE TO
OVER 11%.
NOW MANY OF THOSE GREEN HOUSES
ARE BLOOMING AGAIN AS CANNABIS
PRODUCTION MOVES INTO MONTEREY
COUNTY.
THE COUNTY OF MODERATE OFFICIALS
PREDICTS THAT CANNABIS
AGRICULTURE COULD BRING IN
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
REVENUE.
A NEW TAX REVENUE SO THE COUNTY
STRONGLY SUPPORTS LEGITIMIZING
CANNABIS CULTIVATION AS A
CONTRIBUTION TO THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMITTEE AND ALLOWING CANNABIS
DATA TO BE REPORTED SIMILAR TO
THE COUNTY'S ANNUAL CROP REPORT.
HIGHLIGHTING THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE CROP AND RELATED PRODUCTION
DATA WILL HELP MONTEREY AND
OTHER COUNTIES PROMOTE THIS
AGRICULTURAL PORTFOLIO TO
INVESTORS.
SEEKING TO BACK RESPONSIBLE
OPERATIONS THROUGH DIRECT
FINANCIAL SUPPORT.
IN ADDITION NORMALIZING CANNABIS
AS TRUE AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS
WILL ENCOURAGE UNLICENSED
GROWERS TO COME FORWARD AND
BECOME LEGITIMATE PERMITTED.
AND TAX PAYING BUSINESS AS
MONTEREY COUNTY IS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A LEADER IN THE
PRODUCTION OF COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS IN THE STATE.
AND FOR THESE REASONS FOR
SPONSORING SB SIX FIVE SEVEN
THANK THE SENATOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
IMPORTANT MEASURE AND ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PERSON SPEAKING
SUPPORT PLEASE.
PAUL BOWLES MOVED FROM TH OF
REAL COUNTIES WEIRD STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF CANNABIS PRODUCING
COUNTIES IN OUR MEMBERSHIP WE
SEE THIS AS A TOOL FOR BOTH THE
MARKETING AS WELL AS BETTER
ENFORCEMENT WE ENCOURAGE THIS
BILL TO MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PERSON
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION
TODAY.
IN BETWEEN.
HAVE MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TAYLOR SHE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION BUT WE VERY
MUCH LIKE TO THANK MISTER
MONNING AND OTHER SPONSORS FOR
WORKING THROUGH OUR ISSUES --
NAMELY IT'S IT'S ABOUT
DESIGNATING THAT THE INFORMATION
IS COLLECTED FROM CANNABIS
CULTIVATION IS IN A SEPARATE
REPORT DISTINCT FROM
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS.
WE UNDERSTAND FROM MARKETING
PERSPECTIVE THERE MAY BE VALUE
INCOME MINGLING THOSE PRODUCTS
AND AND HAVING THAT IDEA OF
CANNABIS IS AN AGRICULTURAL
COMMODITY BUT WE THINK STATE LAW
WAS VERY PRESCRIPTIVE THAT THEY
ARE NOT THE SAME -- AND IN DOING
SO WE AGREE THAT DEVELOPING A
SEPARATE PORT HAS VALUE -- BUT
IT DOES NEED TO REMAIN SEPARATE
SO WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THOSE
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
CHAIR.
OF THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
CARRYING THIS I THINK IT'S A
GOOD BILL DOES IT INCLUDE --
HAMP OR IS IT LIMITED TO
CANNABIS JUST CANNABIS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL.
ALL RIGHT THE SEEING NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS ALL AND WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MEMBERS MUCH LET EVERY CROP
ACCOUNTED AT SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX FIVE SEVEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS EGGMAN
BY EGGMAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT LOADING AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I FLORA.
LARA I GRAY.
GRAY AYE IRWIN -- WHEN I JONES
SAWYER?
LEVINE.
LEVINE I ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVAS SIZE SALAS.
SALAS SIGN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
AND SECRETARY IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS LET'S START WITH
SB.
ONE FIFTY THREE A GEAR CURRY
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM I GRAY.
GRAY EYES -- WHEN -- WHEN I? ONE
SB.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE GRAY.
MISS GRAY CANVAS MARKETING YES
SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE GRAY.
GREAT IJONES SAWYER LEVINE.
LEVINE I OKAY.
SB TWO OH TWO WILK ANIMAL BLOOD
BANKS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I GRAY.
GRAY I WENT -- WHEN I?
OKAY ON SB TWO FIFTY THREE JONES
SAWYER [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND AND THEN.
SB FIVE TO SEVEN CARILLO HEMP
AND CANNABIS WILLIAMSON ACT
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS NO.
AND SIX AND SIX FIFTY SEVEN MR
MARIN FIRE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WHAT WE?
GOT.
I THINK ALL ABSENT MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN CALLED.
SO WE WILL NOW ADJOURN THE
MEETING
[inaudible]
THANK